also für mich wenn das wirklich
funktioniert war schon geil weil stellt
euch mal vor ihr habt eine power bank
das ist schön sonnig und ihr könnt
entspannt ihr handy laden damit jetzt
aber schnell sonst ist die sonne gleich
wieder weg also hier ist das ringen
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja die
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich weiß
diesen spot habt ihr schon länger nicht
mehr gesehen also ich glaub ich habe
wirklich lange nicht mehr aus dieser
perspektive aufgenommen erstmal muss ich
mich kurz dafür entschuldigen dass
gestern der daily upload leider
ausgefallen ist jeden tag 19 uhr gibt es
ein neues video auf diesen kanal ich bin
gestern aus dem urlaub wiedergekommen
und das video war nicht ganz fertig
deswegen kam es gestern noch nicht und
kommt irgendwann später diese woche dann
hat das video was heute kommt ist halt
dieses video also es kommt halt wirklich
heute an dem tag wo es auch nämlich muss
allerdings noch ein paar sachen ergänzen
weil ich war in dänemark und schweden
unterwegs die letzten sieben tage und
wollte eigentlich dort dieses gadget
ausprobieren ich zeige es euch mal kurz
hier umgeht
das hat mich ja ich will noch nicht
sagen ob sich überzeugt oder mich wir
haben hier nämlich eine solar power bank
die funktioniert mit sonnenlicht
also lädt halt mit sonne nicht auf ich
habe das ganze match gefunden habt
direkt bestellt genauso wie gefühlt eine
million weitere produkte die jetzt in
zukunft auch um diesen kanal vorgestellt
werden und ich werde die halle testen
ich brauche halt für meinen urlaub noch
eine power bank dann habe ich gedacht
das bietet sich ganz gut an
um die halt einfach mal in der zeit zu
testen ich zeige euch hier mal kurz das
produkt so sieht das aus solarpark usb
für 12 euro hat es gekostet
und ja das war expressversand war auch
ziemlich schnell da deswegen habe ich
das direkt bestellen weil ich habe ja
gedacht eine bank die mit solarenergie
funktioniert und sich selbstständig
auflädt dies heftig also das muss ich
mal ausprobieren
wenn das klappt oder nach für 12 euro
ich war halt neugierig habe direkt
bestellt und ja die rezension dazu waren
alle durchaus positiv also hier fünf
sterne super qualität macht genau das
was es soll sehr schneller versand
josephine hat geschrieben schnelle und
gute lieferung alles wie beschrieben von
anfang an direkt aufgeladen ich muss es
nur noch in der sonne testen und das
habe ich schon gemacht
also ich kenne mich mit dem ding
mittlerweile eigentlich ganz gut aus und
wir springen jetzt mal eben nach
kopenhagen da dieser kleine testflotte
nenne ich es mal also eine mischung aus
technik review und im blog tech blog
alter kranker namen angefangen ich
entschuldige mich für den ton manchmal
ich glaube es war sehr windig dort
synchronisiert danach viel spaß wie
heute gedacht dass ich vielleicht diese
dinge genutzt
hey leute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut und auch und
zwar befinden wir uns gerade christian
kommen noch mal ran gehen und zwar
befinden wir uns gerade zum zweiten mal
in kommen in dänemark wunderschön aber
ich habe noch so ein kleines gadget
bestellt und das war eigentlich sogar
steuer ich glaube es hat fast 30 euro
gekostet
jetzt nehmen wir die story dahinter was
so teuer darf ich jetzt hier richtig
sowie auf jeden fall auch wir können
erst mal rausgehen jungen sie braucht
von einem von euch ein ladekabel glaube
ich dass mit dem von ihr christian dann
könnte man muss sagen dass kasse ist
dieses hotelzimmer oder was falls man
das überhaupt so nennen kann das hat
einfach nur zwei sterne
aber es ist dass kranke zwei sterne
hotel dass ich jeden fall ein ganzes
leben gesehen habe also jetzt so ein
bisschen aufgeräumt aber gebt euch mal
hier haben wir ein bett da haben wir
noch ein bett und zwar ist dass der
solar power bank von riesch hat glaube
ich 20 30 euro kostet keine ahnung und
wir schauen auf die wirklich
funktioniert also die funktioniert wurde
mit sonnenenergie es nötig hat gerade
schon eine leichte befürchtungen dass
wir gar keine sonne haben weil es
ziemlich auf bewölkt ist aber genau hier
raus gegangen sind ist einfach die sonne
rausgekommen und die brauche ich auch
für das video weil ohne sonne kann ich
die solar ding halt nicht treffen und
dass wir natürlich sehr schade weil also
für mich wenn das wirklich funktioniert
wäre schon geil weil stellt euch mal vor
ihr habt so eine power bank hast du
schön sonnig und ihr könnt entspannt
euer handy laden damit jetzt aber
schnell sonst ist die sonne gleich
wieder weg also hier ist das dringend
also wir sind in kopenhagen habe ich
dann gesagt leute hier war ist jetzt
wirklich viel zu wenig das möchte ich
euch nicht antun deswegen habe ich jetzt
ein bisschen drüber
ich hatte 34 prozent akku und habe jetzt
mal die powerman ausgepackt hat
in dieser verpackung spox war da noch so
einen zettel
da stand drauf dass dieses solar feature
auf jeden fall nur das neben feature ist
und ist nur funktioniert wenn extrem
starkes sonnenlicht drauf strahlt genau
also dass heute hier auf jeden fall noch
gesagt haben aber wir hatten auf jeden
fall an manchen tagen extrem knallige
sonne werdet ihr auch gleich sehen dann
habe ich einfach mein handy
angeschlossen die ganzen technischen
sachen sind immer aufgeladen wenn man
sie im internet bestellt auch die power
bank hat halt direkt ganz entspannt
geladen war ganz gut für mich weil ich
hatte nicht mehr viel akku ich habe 31
prozent ja mein ding kann das gut vor
also leute ich muss mich wirklich
entschuldigen für diese schlechte
videoqualität und auch den ton
es tut mir sehr leid es ist einfach viel
zu windig hier und jetzt vorerst von
runde hier roller die gibt es auch in
deutschland das sind eigentlich die
festen kann ich euch empfehlen
[Musik]
dann morgen nur entschuldigung dass die
alle auf mich warten ist ich muss jetzt
noch mal kurz hier ein kleines update
machen
wir möchten den nächsten tag wir sind
schon in stockholm gelandet irgendwo in
unserem ja keine ahnung braucht immer
und das denken ist komplett leer ich
konnte gestern mein handy damit zwei mal
aufladen von null auf hundert also da
war halt noch so sucht traummann kann
die halt auch ganz normal an der
steckdose aufladen aber jetzt schaut mal
wir haben halt kein sonnenlicht hier die
sonne strahlt gar nicht wenn man die
aber unter so licht hält wenn sie an zu
blinken das heißt die lädt jetzt auf und
wir schauen wir ob das wirklich was
bringt das licht das mir jetzt an und
dann gucken wir mal wenn ich wiederkomme
ob die halt dann wieder funktioniert
weiß ja wer ist echt geil
aber ich glaube auch nicht so ganz dran
naja wir sehen uns gleich wieder
ich bin hier gerade wieder am testen und
irgendwie kriege ich nicht hin so
herzlich willkommen zurück ja ich sitze
jetzt wieder hier und ihr habt ja
wahrscheinlich schon gesehen mit dem
solar feature reicht noch nicht so ganz
zufrieden ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz
noch mal wie das funktioniert ich habe
hier eine lampe und hier strahlt er
jetzt sozusagen energie darauf falls das
jetzt physikalisch richtig ausgedrückt
ist und diese lampe hier fängt an zu
leuchten es wird er hier grün das heißt
dieses solarfeld hier registriert halt
eine lichtquelle
wenn ich also jetzt weg mache und die so
halte ist es halt aus das gleiche
passiert auch wenn ihr in der prallen
sonne liegt ich hatte die einmal
wirklich zehn stunden unter der lampe
und dann noch einmal zwei stunden in der
sonne und das resultat war er nicht so
gut also sie hat überhaupt keine energie
erzeugt und dann handy aufzuladen
das heißt wenn ich jetzt mein handy hier
anschließe passiert leider absolut gar
nichts außer dass die hat plötzlich ja
jetzt hat es aufgehört ja genau außer
dass sie plötzlich so blau blinkt warum
sie das tut weiß ich nicht deswegen muss
ich hier zu deiner sagen auch wenn es
auf den produktfotos wirklich toll
aussieht funktionieren tut halt nicht
also solarpark ist für mich was anderes
hätte ich allerdings auch wirklich krass
gefunden für 12 euro ich hab dir jetzt
noch mal ganz normal mit dem kabel an
strom angeschlossen und hier sehen weil
wir es passiert ja auch wirklich was
also ja jetzt lädt die glaube ich auch
und dann denke ich auch ist es eine bank
die wie jede andere stumpfe power bin
ganz normal funktionieren wird dann
stellt sich für mich die frage warum das
mit dem solar feature was halt
eigentlich keins ist also grob
zusammengefasst meine neugier und freude
auf das produkt war ziemlich hoher einer
hat es mich ein bisschen enttäuscht also
es gab schon wesentlich coole sachen ich
dort bestellte ab jappy bringen jetzt
mal ein bisschen laden lassen und jetzt
stecken wir noch mal ab ob das jetzt
lädt also müsst ihr eigentlich nur sonst
ist die kacke das komische ist jetzt
dieses kabel habe ich von roche das ist
ein leuchtendes iphone ladekabel ist
nämlich einfach mal ein originales
hacker und das lädt jetzt also jetzt
funktioniert ist wie gesagt ich habe
mein handy damit mal komplett aufgeladen
ich weiß nicht wie viele ladungen da
drauf sind ich würde mal so auf zwei
tippen ist aber auf keinen fall ein
produkt was ich euch empfehlen kann holt
euch dann lieber irgendwie hier im media
markt
ich glaube da kosten die auch nicht mehr
als zwölf oder 13 14 15 euro keine
ahnung das war es mit dem nächsten
wischtest ich hoffe mein tech blog hat
euch trotzdem gefallen für weitere
techblogs das gern nach oben da schreibt
weitere ideen für produkte in die
kommentare oder schreibt mir eure video
wünsche und ideen per instagram 30 alex
wie ich freue mich immer darüber wir
sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr wieder jetzt
geht es erstmal los youtube gaming party
gamescom geil haut rein job
[Musik]